Hello and welcome to Holotalk, the internet radio broadcast for lasers and holography, enjoyed by listeners throughout the world.
I'm Frank Defratis, and I'll be your host for each installment, bringing you news, guests, and everything holographic.
Now please enjoy the latest show.
Hello, Frank Defratus.
Frank, hi, it's Inyaki here, calling from the UK.
How are you?
Uh fine, very well, thank you.
And you?
Pretty good.
Thank you for calling.
Not at all.
Oh, it's it's the perfect time.
Welcome to Holotalk.
Thanks very much.
I uh I just did one of the Apollo astronauts yesterday.
That's amazing.
Wow, what what's his name?
His name is Dr.
Edgar Mitchell.
He was the captain that took the module down onto uh onto the moon's surface.
Oh right.
Yeah.
That is incredible.
So you're in good company.
Um absolutely amazing.
Wow.
Because NASA were I mean, NASA were involved in holography at one one point, weren't they?
Oh yeah, very much so.
But uh Dr.
Mitchell is more involved with um the holographic theory of the universe and how it applies to extrasensory perception and uh thought, human thought.
Right.
Okay, yeah.
Very very similar to uh Pribram's uh uh theory of the holographic brain and things of that nature.
Fantastic.
Yeah.
Well, it's good to have you on the show.
Excellent, thank you very much.
You're a uh fellow pseudo color holographer.
Rice, okay.
That's it, yeah.
I mean, have you have you um have you been involved in that kind of stuff before as well?
It's it's my favorite type of hologram to do.
Although I must admit I don't remember seeing many pseudo color holograms where someone color mixes the way that you do.
Usually the individual exposures and the individual colors are independent of one another within the hologram.
You actually do the color mixing where if it's a bronze type of statue, the statue turns out bronze from using pseudocolor technique.
Absolutely.
I mean, you know, it's it's it's it's a bit more challenging, I suppose, trying to tr trying to achieve, you know, very specific colors.
What got you started and what made you choose doing pseudocolor?
And also explain to the listeners exactly what pseudocolor is.
Uh pseudocolor really is is creating colors in a sense artificially.
Um so you're you're using um chemistry, you're using um in this in in my case a chemical called uh trietinolomy, I think probably in most other people's case as well.
Um and and so by by swelling the uh silver halide emulsion to a to a controlled extent, you can you can basically control the color, the ac the the outcome of the color of the uh of the reflection hologram.
So um you can di I suppose both for for for um for reflection and transmission, but I I mean I I I specifically concentrate on on reflection holograms because they're just holograms I prefer.
You know, I prefer the the the the parallax in both directions and and and the fixed colours.
I mean that's what really appeals to me with the with the with the reflection hologram.
And it's an easier hologram to sell uh compared to a white light transmission hologram which has to be out in the middle of a room or away from the wall so that the light can sh you know go through it.
But I mean that is true and and I mean you know pe with transmission holograms people have have put mirrors behind them and things but it it it rarely um you know has the same effect of of of of uh of lighting a transmission hologram how you should, which is basically from behind, you know, you you'd lose a certain certain amount of the um the the brightness I suppose.
Um so reflection holograms are easier um to to to eliminate than transmission holograms that that's that's certainly true and I suppose as a result they're very easy to sell.
Yeah, yeah.
Now you you're a scientist by trade and uh and by learning.
Is that correct?
Is that how how you would describe yourself compared to say describing yourself as an artist or a combination of both, which is extremely important.
Um I I would say combination of both actually yeah I mean I I I sort of I I initially I took the scientific route.
I mean I I became interested in holograms when I was about um twelve or thirteen um back in in probably about nineteen eighty four, nineteen eighty five.
And um I I I went to a uh an art exhibition in London actually and saw my saw the hologram sort of for the first time.
It was a a photographic exhibition com combining photographs and holograms.
And um I I was just you know fascinated from them you know right right from the beginning.
And so actually what I then went went on to do was was um I studied physics at at Imperial College in London uh you know part well mainly because of my interest in in in holography and lasers.
Um but uh but uh in recent years I've I've been sort of you know doing more uh creative and artistic it works really because um I think I think there's there's a there's a huge amount of potential there with with the pseudocolour work.
Are you familiar with um Steve McGrew's hinge point geometry?
Yes, yes reasonably yes when we're doing a pseudocolour hologram and each of the individual exposures are independent of one another as far as forming or reconstructing in the three dimensional space the responsibility of registration with that image is not there.
But with the work that you're doing where you're uh colour combining to create uh additive and subtractive colours registration is extremely important for you.
Yeah, I mean absolutely and and th there are certain tricks.
You know you can you have to you have you do have to think very carefully about the subject matter.
Um I mean although you know if you look at the images I've done they there seems that there is quite a sort of diverse range of different images, different types of images, but you know you I I do think very carefully to begin with about how I'm going to you know shoot the holograms, the the separate colours, how I'm going to separate the colours out, how easy it's going to be, is it going to be an issue with with registration and if there is, then I ha I really have to take that into consideration.
So for example, um one of one of the the the key points to remember is when you do a hologram of of something that's going to be multicolor, the using the pseudocolour process, the closer the elements are to the image plane, the easier it is to register.
I mean, it's very difficult to have a very deep image and have all the colours in register uh right from the front to the to the back of the of the of the subject matter through the image plane.
So you have to you have to think about these things very carefully.
Um and you know, if I'm honest, you you never you never get the registration absolutely perfect.
You can get it perfect on on the surface of the hologram, but as you come forward from the from the surface and go back, the the real and virtual image, you you you you actually you always have to compromise really.
Um so it's it's it's a tricky one.
But i i it's one of those things you never know until you've shot the hologram you spent weeks shooting the hologram and whether it's whether it's actually worked and whether you can get away with the with the the slight misregistration if there is any.
Yeah.
Have you ever done any single beam pseudocolour work.
Yeah, I mean that was what I started off with actually and um it was uh I mean it the the the deniger cologram is is is great fun but it it's it was slightly limiting.
You you couldn't really achieve the brightness that I wanted to achieve um and you know some some people might argue with with that point but I I found it difficult to to to get the brightness um that that I wanted to achieve and and and so I I moved on to the the split beam work and and the sort of H1H2 mastering transfer setups where you had more control in a sense of the uh of the sort of the beam ratios and path length and all the rest of it.
I noticed on your website uh a few pictures of your laboratory and uh you're certainly working with some high end professional equipment there.
It's not like you have uh something stacked on top of cement blocks.
I mean that's how I started.
I mean I started with the um I built a s uh uh a a sand table um i in in the in a shed at the bottom of my my parents garden quite a few years ago and and uh and so you know th m that was when I was about sort of fifteen or something.
And um to be honest, I was you know, the the the sand table is is as good in many ways as as the the sort of the high end um Newport or Mel's Greo obstacle tables that you can buy today.
I mean it was a very, very stable system that I had.
Um you know, the the down side of sand obviously is that y it it ruins optics very easily, but um I f I find it is a very fluid type of system to use for table geometry and lighting setups.
A sand table.
Absolutely.
Very easy to work with in that respect.
Yeah, and and incredibly stable.
I mean it's it's really it's a very good um, you know, dancing medium, so i it works just as well as um you know the the the expensive optical tables.
I mean I've I've built up a a sort of uh a certain amount of equipment over the years really just by by you know, buying things when I could afford them and and uh sort of buying second hand on on on the internet and things.
So um at the m so now I've got uh I've I've got I've got a lab that's pretty pretty well equipped to be honest with you.
But um I don't think that should put anybody off but y you know, that you I mean you can you can produce good holograms um on a on a very limited budget.
When I I mean when I was when when I had my sand table I I used to go down to the uh the scrap metal merchants and get bits of steel and and sort of weld them together and and the the the you know as mirror mounts or optical posts or whatever and they were just as good as uh as the stuff that you the expensive stuff that you can buy from you know from from the optical companies.
I I started off with a small breadboard uh um that was three by five feet and um and I used that for for for for quite a few years after the sand table and that was that was brilliant 'cause it was just about two people could just about lift it and and take it from one place to another so it was it was you know transportable basically.
Now obviously if you're working with um uh the pseudo colour work with reflection holography you're going to have to work with a red laser.
What type of uh red laser are you using?
Are you using a gas laser?
I'm using a helium neon gas laser yeah um a a fairly old spectrophysics um I can't remember the model number, but it's about twenty five thirty milliwatts.
Okay.
Yeah.
And so I've I you know I've I've with with that laser I produced holograms up to um thirty by forty centimeters.
Yeah yeah pseudo colour.
Um and that I mean that's the other advantage of pseudocolour is you you you know you you you only need the one laser and um I was I was producing ho um good pseudocolor reflection holograms up to eight by ten inches with a with a five milliwatt um heane that I had before.
So you can you ri you really don't need um an awful lot of power.
And you also need to have the ability to um make sure that the emulsion does not shrink in the final hologram.
So you have to have a processing regimen that if you're shooting with six thirty three the untreated exposure has to be six thirty three or it's going to affect your other colours as well.
If it's not asking uh too much proprietary information what type of processing regimen do you use?
Um I I use the standard processing which which um which many people use for reflection holograms and that's a pyrogalol based uh developer.
So um ten grams of of uh pyrogalol uh in a litre of water and and uh sixty grams of sodium carbonate in a litre of water and then when you when you make the hologram you mix those two parts two um parts together just before uh developing and it I mean I I found it works very very well it g it it seems to give the the the most consistent and and the brightest results and I've experimented with with other chemistry and with other um sort of formulas and and to be honest I I still get the best results with with the pyro based developer.
Yeah that's what I use to use the dichromate bleach?
No I don't use EDA rehalogenating bleach.
Oh is it see I've never used that EDTA bleach yet but everybody seems to be really crazy about it.
I've never tried it yet.
It works I mean the dichromates is is a is a nice uh simple bleach and it it it probably works um just as well but EDTA is is is always the the been the bleach has always been the bleach that I've used and um I I must admit I think it gives just very slightly better results.
Yeah.
Uh and more consistency.
You know with the whole process there are there are a lot of um you know there's a the there's a lot of variables and so it you know it can be frustrating because you can start off with exactly the right colours one day and then you you've produced exactly go through the same process the next day and something's changed the the temperature or the humidity in the in the in the lab and and the the colours that you get are are are very different.
So although I try and control everything as best I can it's um it's still it's still difficult.
And y it can be immensely frustrating sometimes because you you can spend a long a long time trying to get the colours you want, achieve them and then put a test and then move on to the full plate and you and you end up with something completely different voids.
I mean there's also the batch of emulsion and things which which makes a big difference.
Yeah, the hardness or software.
Yeah.
I I've also noticed that uh the holograms that I've done in the past that I have hanging here in the studio, depending on the season there's color shift as well.
In the in the winter time I I have actually uh hot air heat here.
So the atmosphere inside gets rather dry in the winter time and the emulsion shrinks.
And then in the location where we are it gets very humid in the summer and the emulsion expands.
And you get your you get your color shift for each one of the exposures accordingly to whatever the relative humidity of the it takes a long time for it to do.
It's not you know immediate but over a week or a week and a half you start to notice that you're um in with more humidity your reds are going into your deeper blood reds and in the winter time uh with the dry air that the uh reds are actually starting to creep a little bit towards the orange.
Yeah, yeah absolutely I mean this is with sealed holograms too.
You you they're sealed are they?
I mean it's very it's very difficult to to to control really and and um you know again sometimes it can be can be frustrating i if you're if you if you've um you've made a hologram and the colours are absolutely as far as you're concerned they're absolutely spot on in in your lab and then you take them off to to an exhibition where the temperature's much higher and and the colours you know they sort of go way off and and i it you know it can be it can be frustrating but I think I mean I think it purely depends on on the on the temperature on and temperature and the humidity basically and and how much the emulsion um sort of shrinks by and in in in one particular situation or expands in the other situation.
I mean it's it's it's very it's it's very difficult to control really.
And of course the the angle of the hologram, although it's designed to be illuminated at the angle you shoot it more or less, the you can change uh the the reconstruction angle um or the angle that you illuminate the hologram at and and and that will shift the colours as well.
Yeah.
Yeah, I noticed with the uh hinge point geometry that I spoke about earlier, it's actually uh a little bit of a different angle for each one of the ex uh color exposures.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
A different placement of the uh actual uh diverging lens as well.
Yes.
Very interesting mathematics involved with that.
Yeah, I mean it it's it they're complicated and I I must admit, uh I mean Steve's an i an incredible person.
I I d I I really um although I I use the uh um you know the technique and things I don't I don't pretend to understand it particularly well to be honest with you.
Um so it was there is a lot of maths involved in that and uh maths although I've got a degree in physics, it's not it's not actually my strong point really.
Well, you know what you're doing, even though your your background is science and your formal training is in physics and science, the actual process of what you're doing is very, very much a craft.
You're a craftsperson.
Yeah.
And uh is that important to you to maintain that or uh wouldn't it matter to you if you were to go to say uh three color laser and just start doing full color holography?
Is this something specifically that you want to do as a craftsperson?
Is this pseudocolor holography?
I mean there is something uh immensely satisfying about about you know spending a long time essentially crafting this this this piece uh together and and ending up over over maybe a period of weeks or whatever with with with something that you're happy with um as opposed to um pressing a button on a machine or I mean the true colour holography really is is also very interesting but it it just gives a uh difficulty putting it into words really but it gives a very different type of image.
It gives more like a scientific recording of a uh of a of a of an object.
It's very accurate.
Um but it's not necessarily particularly appealing to look at.
It's like comparing a a digital DVD to seeing it with film.
Exactly.
I mean it is difficult to say precisely what it is, but um uh th there's there's something there.
It's uh it's almost too refined.
Um so yeah, I mean I I if I mean I suppose originally the reason I went into pseudocolour uh sort of headed in that in that down that route rather than true colour was simply because I didn't have the the funds to um to do true colour.
Um but but really what I've discovered is that is that pseudocolour um can can actually offer more as a creative artistic technique than than true colour in in quite a few ways actually.
Um what ways would you say they are?
Well it can it if you if you have an object um the the pseudo colour can actually uh enhance the features, the colours um I mean I I I've made quite a few holograms of glass for example, and the diffraction effects that you get on on glass um in the hologram can can r are really exaggerated.
And so they they they transform this sort of fairly ordinary looking piece of glass into something quite special.
Um and and you don't I mean I have experimented with true colour and you just don't get the same kind of effect.
Maybe it's simply because of the diffraction efficiency, the brightness of the hologram.
Um but uh but I have a feeling there's a few other things there as well, really.
Um so yeah, it's a combination of different things really, and and um I I I think I think the pseudo color has the potential um you know to be to be uh more creative in a sense.
One of the pseudocolor works that I did was a three-color piece, and I took plexiglass and put it into the oven until it got soft.
And when it came out of the oven, I bent the plexiglass and twisted it in different dimensions while it was still soft, then spray painted the plexiglass black, and while the spray paint was still wet, I would take paint brushes and make different areas where it would make the plexiglass clear.
And I also take uh cotton swabs on some of them, and I would dabble the cotton swabs on the different pieces of plexiglass.
And then what I would do is rear illuminate them, sort of like a shadogram in a sense, the shadogram geometry, rear illuminate them, and the areas that I used the uh paint brushes on and the cotton swabs would allow the laser light to come through.
And each one of the uh pieces of plexiglass I did a separate color uh s for s uh three color pseudocolor hologram, and a lot of the different areas actually occupied the same di uh three dimensional space, and one of the paint brush swabs would actually go through an area of the cotton swabs.
And I noticed on your webpage a lot of the holog the holograms are absolutely gorgeous, and you you seem to be uh almost documenting already existing objects and I was just curious do you have any plans uh for now or in the future of actually uh using something else other than already existing objects in your work.
Yeah.
I mean I've I've done uh you know I haven't done an awful lot of abstract um holograms but I've but I've done a few um and uh I mean I've th there's one um which I was particularly pleased with called color wave.
Uh I think that's on the website, I'm pretty sure it is actually.
And and and that actually that was I mean plexigas is like perspective, isn't it really?
Is that what you call uh essentially perspecs, isn't it?
Yeah it's it's a frosted type of uh plastic.
A lot of people will use them in the like shower doors so that they don't have real glass and things like that.
It's a similar technique for for creating that that the sculpture basically the the the the color wave.
Okay.
And um so but that was basically one of the the sort of first abstract uh more abstract pieces that I did.
I suppose the the the the earlier stuff like um uh the the the one of Gromid for example, I mean that was that was just simply a model that I saw and I and to me that was a technical challenge to try and um that was one of the very earliest pieces I did back in nineteen ninety seven.
So I I just from a technical point of view wanted to recreate that in the hologram and make it as as bright as possible and and um as as technically uh perfect as possible.
And um so I pick I'd pick something like that, which would which for from a technical point of view very challenging.
Um from a creative point of view apart from the creative process of of making the hologram, um mean it not so challenging.
But but now I I'm I am moving more into the sort of abstract uh um type images.
Yeah.
And um I I f I find that very interesting.
I'll make sure that there's a link to your website on the HoloTalk page so uh people will be able to listen to the show and go over and visit your site and you also have holograms for sale over there as well.
Uh they'll have to do the conversion I guess from what is it uh called there, uh British sterling or British pounds or something and uh yeah, uh pound sterling.
Yeah.
So what is it just pretty much for uh uh US funds just double that amount I would imagine or so, is that correct?
At the moment it's uh it's it's roughly roughly double, so yeah.
Roughly.
Since we're coming up on almost a half an hour already, I was wondering if there's uh anything that you'd like to add to the interview that we didn't talk about?
Um I c I can't think of it.
I mean, is is there anything that you you'd like me to add, let's put it that way.
Oh well.
Um I mean I could I could carry on talking for hours.
Oh, I bet you could.
I'd love to talk for hours.
It's I I have to keep the file sizes small because of all the people that download the files.
Some of them overseas don't have high speed connections and believe it or not, there's still people that are going on the internet with fourteen four modems and twenty eight eight modems.
Are you?
So it would take quite a bit of time for you to download one of these shows on one of those modems.
Yeah, I think.
So that's why I try and keep it uh I'd love to talk to people for an hour or more, and I know there's plenty of things to talk about.
But uh absolutely.
Yeah.
So do you do you exhibit your do you have any exhibits of your holograms coming up that you'd like to promote or is there anything that you'd like to promote?
Do you have workshops?
Um I d I I don't at the moment actually and and exhibitions, I mean the last exhibition I did actually was at the um uh the the conference in in Wales, um where they had an exhibition at one of one of the castles down there.
D is there anyone that you have that was an influence for you?
Um I'll be honest th th there wasn't really because there's been so little Pseudocolour work really done.
Um Were you familiar with John Kaufman?
The name John Kaufman?
I've seen some of his stuff quite quite recently actually.
Um and in fact there was an exhibition of his his work over here about about um six months or a year ago.
Um Melissa Crenshaw is another name that did some beautiful uh pseudocolar work.
I I met her in in um in Wales.
In Wales, yeah.
And and the thing is it's very difficult and f I find it uh I still find it quite difficult to find sort of um information about these people and and and photographs 'cause I mean one of the one of the w w at the um the conference I actually gave a talk on sort of you know, the the history of of pseudocolour work and and um and I missed out a few people, not uh not intentionally but simply because I I didn't know that they they they produced that uh that that these kinds of holograms and it's just been it's just quite difficult to find um information on it to be honest with you.
Yeah.
It is very difficult to find information on it.
I think Lon Moore's another name.
I I I hope I'm not gonna be able to do that.
Oh Lon Moore certainly I've I've heard of, yeah.
I hope I'm not forgetting people and if I do I apologize.
But to get back to what you were originally talking about when I impolitely interrupted you, you.
You said you have uh uh e exhibits coming up.
Um I don't actually at the moment.
No.
Um nothing nothing uh um in the imminent future, but I I I hope to be organising um something for perhaps later in the year.
How do you feel about that?
There you know to me, with the type of work that you do and the quality of that work you sh you should be turning shows down because there's too many of them trying to get you work.
How do you feel about I mean that that's just insanity to me.
That's absolute insanity.
I mean it is it is in a way.
Um i it's it's it's partly my fault I think because I don't push it enough and and you know I've I've I've sort of involved in so many other things as well and and it's really a question of finding the time because uh you know setting up a an exhibition properly is is is is something that takes a lot of time and and effort and and quite a large quite a large amount of money as well sometimes.
So um but but so I I I am certainly partly to blame for for not uh for for not pushing my stuff enough.
I've I mean I've literally only within the past six months um organised my my website and that's something I've been meaning to do for years.
Um but yeah I mean there there are very few places that that that um sort of exhibit holograms on a regular basis.
It's I mean it's as simple as that and and uh in the UK we used to have you know three or four galleries that were were dedicated to exhibiting holograms and and various other galleries such as the photography galleries that that would be um putting on regular exhibitions of holograms.
Now now there's no one.
I mean well was there's there's Jonathan Ross who who has his his gallery in London.
Yes.
But um but th very, very few people.
Very very few venues where you can you can exhibit your holograms.
So i it is difficult.
It's very difficult.
And of course it's very difficult to for people to get an idea of what they're like really on the i on on the internet looking at looking at photographs.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
That's heartbreaking.
It is in a way.
But I I hope I hope that um I hope the interest will come back.
Mm-hmm.
Well, folks like yourself with the work that you're doing, I'm I'm sure that'll help, you know, w having people see the uh quality and uh and the care and the craftsmanship that goes into crafts personship that goes into uh the work that you do.
Yeah, well I mean, you know, the the the more people that try it the the the better really and I and I think that um I think what what you're doing and and the you know, for example the holography forum at the minute's just it's a fantastic idea and uh it's it's great to see that there are people out there that are um that are experimenting with this and and and trying uh and making holograms because sometimes you wonder if there's anyone else out there that's making holograms.
Yeah.
But sometimes it's a good thing to turn a computer off and get involved in your own community at the local community level as well.
So I'd like to say that to people, you know, 'cause I know I know sometimes we're we think what a wonderful global community we have on the internet and a lot of times the time that we take, you know, with this global electronic uh phosphorus screen communications, uh we let other I wouldn't say more important things, but just important as far as our local communities, uh our local arts organizations and things of that nature we just don't bother with because we have such a wonderful community online.
But online's not gonna do it.
You know, it's it's the people on the street that's spending more time talking to people uh uh the other side of the world than we do uh next door.
Yeah, that's true.
Well, I want to thank you very much for taking the time to come on the show.
I know it's gonna be a great show.
And I think this will probably this will probably go up in February sometime, I would imagine.
I've got uh the Apollo astronaut up there right now.
Then there's a large holography exhibit that's coming uh not too far from where I live at one of the museums here that's uh have been curated by uh Paul Barefoot who put the original Museum of Holography traveling exhibit of um uh through the looking glass together.
So I have to I ac that opens on February third, so the next show has to be uh the one that I did earlier today with the uh marketing director of the museum, and then you'll go up after that.
How's that?
Fantastic.
But at least we have it finished.
I hope to get a chance to meet you sometime.
If you're ever in the States, I'm only about a little bit over an hour, maybe depending on traffic, an hour and a half away from New York City and only an hour away from New uh from Philadelphia.
So if you're ever in the States and you're in those areas, please let me know.
I'd love to meet you.
That would be fantastic.
Yeah.
And if I mean if you can't come to me, I'll come to you, but if you can come here, you know, come, we'll have a nice dinner and everything, you know.
That that would be brilliant.
And I mean, I'd be I'd be really interested to know because I've heard a lot of I've heard your name mentioned, you know, m many times, and um but never know never known quite where you sort of fit into the picture.
Uh you've been involved in holography for many years, is that right?
Since I was popping pimples.
Fantastic.
It's uh it's holography, so I'm glad I'm not the only one.
All right.
Take care.
Yeah, and you.
Speaking soon.
Bye bye.